las vegas now whether you are going out
on the town for valentine's day or
keeping it casual or even just hanging
out with your girlfriends you still need
to find the perfect outfit and you can
do that at downtown summerlin here to
get us inspired and show us some fun
looks is haley harzinski from downtown
summerlin haley good to see you again
great to see you we get to talk all
things pink and valentine's day this is
going to be really fun so let's get
right to it let's bring out our first
model to talk about a fun look we have
here so today we have serenity and she
you know went with the classic sweater
dress and it's this is perfect for if
you want to stay warm and it has a
little shimmer to it which is a little
fun and it's fun because you can throw
on a little booty or a little stiletto
and go out the door and you're ready for
date night i love this i like anything
with sparkles so i'm loving the gliss
element to this and yeah you never know
it's gonna be a little bit chilly so
this has you covered just in case
absolutely all right let's bring out our
next look over here come on out i'm
seeing more pink yep come on so we have
bridget here this look is from express
from head to toe and what i love about
this is it's just a really fun flirty
satin bodysuit and has a billowy sleeve
and then these pants are my favorite
they're black coated so they look like
leather with the silk smooth
look that she has but it actually is
very comfortable high-waisted and
perfect for a little edgy flirty look
yeah you're working those pants i
thought they were leather so i just i
have to feel them oh my gosh those are
so fun okay i need to get a pair of
those all right let's bring our next
model out over here i love the red
jumpsuit the red jumpsuit is iconic
right this says boss babe vibes she has
a
super cute clutch from francesca's as
well as the body suit and this is great
because you can go bold with accessories
so you can do big great big necklaces
earrings clutches and throw on some
heels and then go out with the
girlfriends or on a hot date i think i
shop at downtown summerlin too much
because i knew that that clutch was from
francesca it's so cute will you hold
that purse up so we can see it says love
that is really really fun oh i'm loving
that out yeah look how cute that is oh
something fun for everyone and i have to
mention too that my dress i actually
found at dillard's at downtown summerlin
and i went for this dress because it's
kind of fun i can wear it here at work
or i can wear it out for girls night out
date night a little bit of everything
right absolutely valentine's day is the
perfect excuse to get dressed up and
have fun i love it well let's bring our
models back in i'll have you guys kind
of strut the runway as you come back in
and haley just real quick in addition to
shopping you could also hang out at
downtown summerlin and have a meal and
make a whole day out of it yeah you can
celebrate all weekend long we have over
30 dining options for every palette so
whether you're looking for somewhere to
take the family cpk is perfect you want
that fun sexy vibe we've got jing
lanetta so many options for everyone
yeah jing is my hangout so and look
we're also color corner coordinated i
feel like we all just have to go out and
have a fun night together well haley
thank you so much thank you to our
models let's all give one more pose we
got to see these looks all right there
you go
all right mercedes i'll send it over to
you